be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are continuing on with the
boys and I woke up a little bit ago you
guys get that extra sexy morning boys as
we go through the video though this
voice is going to go away so enjoy while
it lasts ah but nonetheless
okay so we're picking up with the boys
and and we're picking up with season
volume 3 volume whatever it is we're on
ah good for the soul
now this one's pretty solid right like
here's the thing about the boys some of
the stories are hit and miss right like
some of the volumes are hitting this and
a lot of you guys have picked that up
already a lot of the guys are kind of
like okay so like not all of these are
winners right but like a lot of them are
and this one I think is actually really
really good and initially this picks up
with starlight right now the character
of starlight has been having more or
less like a crisis of conscience since
she joined the 7 that's been like the
core basis behind her character that she
was a kid who was part of like Heartland
America right she was she was there as
part of the superhero team she grew up
you know as a superhero in Middle
America is a very conservative part of
the country kind of homey and kind of
innocent in terms of how she functioned
as she grew older she really maintained
that mindset so once you got into her
older years right like you once she
basically joined as part of the 7 what
she came to realize is that the
superhero as she viewed it was not the
way it was but this is an interesting
concept because what it really seems to
point to is the idea that there's the
world in which we think it is then
there's the world the way it actually is
and the question is if you have to
choose one which one do you pick and
that's been the struggle of Starlite
like she's just kind of like this
wide-eyed innocent girl who's brand-new
to the world doesn't really have any
idea how it works and then what she gets
into it she realizes wow it's totally
different that she has to basically find
a way to navigate those waters and
that's one of the things that she's
talking about she's kind of sitting here
sort of speaking directly to Jesus just
sort of like I don't really know what
all I'm doing like I don't I don't
really know if I should believe in any
of this you know she talked about how
it's been six months is all this really
seemed to start and she was sitting in
on a meeting of the 7 and when she was
there it was basically this kinda like
hey there's this guy from Vaughn
American this sits in there and he's
there with people that could tear his
head off like that right he's there with
people they could push their fingers
through titanium he's in a room with
some of the most physically and capable
powerful people in the world and he's in
charge
he knows he's the one that runs the show
and that's what was always kind of
interesting to me about the boys but you
know you have these various characters
here you have these guys and those you
guys you know the answer to this
question don't spoil it we're kind of
running with the suspension of disbelief
here but you have like some super
powerful characters here some beings who
are in a lot of ways gods walking in the
earth and they're answering to a
corporation right what what stops them
from toppling everything and just like
conquering the world is saying like we
run everything now
like what military is gonna be able to
stop them and so it's an interesting
concept because again it really sort of
hits home with her basically meeting
with with Victor vite now Victor via the
vice-president at the moment one of the
things to talk about here because we
haven't really discussed him too much we
sort of left this it's kind of a thing
that was out there and haven't really
had a whole lot of discussion with it so
the sitting president at the time is
Dakota Bob and Dakota Bob is a guy who
does not want to have any superhero
members of the community right there's
seven or anybody else he does not want
their hands in like the military right
he's one of them in the Department of
Defense or anything like that they stay
over there doing their thing the US
government and so on stay over here
doing their thing Vic the veep is is
really fought Americans answer to solve
that question right like to basically
get the president out and then have
victory become the new president and
then implement policies that would be
wildly difficult to reverse to basically
have like the superheroes as part of the
defense system right the the US Defense
Department this really shows us like the
full-on desire of Vaud American and
really like what all it is they want to
achieve right because what American is
not just a company looking to achieve
mass amounts of wealth you know with
regards to using superheroes as a means
to you know get out there and sell
comics and all kinds of merchandising
and so on and so forth bought American
is looking to attain power and to be
this kind of hidden clandestine hand
behind the individual who runs the free
world is a huge amount of power and
that's one of the things that that that
starlight really seems to struggle with
because as she goes through this it
actually sort of makes her way you know
through the through the sevens
headquarters she begins to realize that
like they're trying to find a way to get
her out or they're trying to find a way
to get rid of her and the reality behind
this is because she just doesn't fit in
this world she's too young she's too
innocent she's too naive to really
understand how the world works is a cool
little thing here because it's kind of
like is she capable of handling it in
this world is she capable of making it
here or she just gonna be one of these
individuals who kind of free floats
hoping she can change it one day and
never really being successful in doing
that that's kind of this struggle that
she's coping with now again those you
guys know the answer don't spill the
beans
I know telling the internet not to do
something is usually a terrible idea but
the fact remains here there's a lot of
things that Starlights struggling with
he's really kind of having an
existential crisis and a lot of ways
what am I doing here
why is nothing what I thought it would
be it's a cool little discussion here
and it's a good way to focus on her
character in a way that we don't
normally see
Neverland there you switch over to Huey
basically hanging out with a legend or
at least going to see the legend now the
idea behind this is he starts asking
questions like do Billy butcher in them
no and the reason
no they don't know that kind of thing so
it really looks like Huey is sort of
doing something on his own this isn't a
huge thing at the moment right it's not
a very big thing right now
but really the brunt of his first issue
really focuses on the struggle of
starlett right like one of the things
she says is like I need to get back home
I need to get back home get back to my
roots I needed to go back in and and
really I need to see like the warmth of
drummer boy this kid that I was in love
with you know the two of us were you
know kind of having our own thing albeit
in a more conservative fashion I want to
get back home get back to my roots and
find some sense of normalcy and so
ultimately she ends up traveling back to
see drummer boy now what you end up
learning here is that when starlight was
part of like this you know kind of
homegrown grassroots Middle American
superhero team that when she was there
that it was kind of like like she was
literally the one who was kind of
holding everybody back right she was one
who was kind of like we can't say like
the S word and we have to keep it super
conservative super Christian and like
you know she was kind of the face of the
team in a lot of ways right like how
people viewed her is how they view the
team as well for the most part it kept a
lot of people in order but this is kind
of the reality of the situation that
she's in right like nothing is what
she's seen and that's why it's important
to keep in mind that while starlight is
an interesting character she is
incredibly naive why she's an incredibly
naive and and and really sort of
baseline character right but it is kind
of kind of interesting to see that sort
of innocence in this environment and to
see what this innocence will become as
the series goes on but again it's sort
of intriguing there because ultimately
what she really begins to ask is is God
real right if God has a plan for
everyone then that means everything
that's going on is part of God's plan
right like if God exists out there and
and God could stop these terrible things
I think God's not stopping these
terrible things which means God must be
okay with it which means God's not what
I thought he was and ultimately
starlight kind of seems to walk away and
that's what she runs back into Huey now
up to this point
Huey hasn't really been a romantic love
interest for starlight so much as
somebody that she can confide and even
then it was only ever really a couple of
times right she was like she doesn't
really know him and that's one of the
things that she kind of says here you
know when the two of them are talking
when when he basically says hey look you
know everything will be okay and I'm
somebody that you can confide in she
really likes kind of sort of spilling
the beans about everything about not
really everything she's done insofar as
like performing inappropriate actions as
she deemed it with members of the seven
but at the very least and saying there's
things that I've done over the course of
my life you know recently that I'm not
proud of and it's called into question
my entire view of God and whether or not
he's real my entire life philosophy has
just been thrown into disarray and I
don't really know how to interpret it
but as she starts talking to Huey of
course she really kind of starts hitting
at the idea that like I don't really
oh you like I don't know you that well
but I feel like I do like there's
there's something about Hughey that
really strikes starlight in such a way
to where he's someone that she can just
kind of open up to you now this usually
goes one of two ways right for every guy
out there who's been in this boat this
goes one of two ways either it's man it
can really open up to you because you're
a great friend friend-zoned or i can
open up to you and i could definitely
see myself knockin boots like it's one
of those only ever goes one of those two
ways right
luckily for Huey it goes the good way
Huey doesn't get stuck in the friend
zone and he gets a chance to knock those
boots and cuz basically like he asked
your dad says hey like you want to get a
drink sometime
and her response is like yeah I noticed
this gentleman all right head inside
track here for a second gentleman notice
this right the guys should get the girls
are the ones who make the move not the
ones who sit back like I'm gonna be a
gentleman and let her make the first
move no because that is weakness that is
lame you want something get out there
and get it right the world the world is
just bring it to you right women don't
want a guy who just rests on their
laurels hoping that one day they'll get
the girl if they tell her everything she
wants to hear and if they're nice to her
100% of the time and if they never
acknowledge her faults no you're gonna
get laughed at you're gonna get stuck in
the friend zone and she's gonna end up
going out and getting somebody else so
be the one who makes the move and don't
be afraid to call people out right like
have some backbone now from there it
switches over to the voice and this is a
cool thing about this is because we knew
the boys were keeping tabs on the seven
in a lot of different ways what this
shows is the resiliency and it really
shows like how deep reaching and how far
down like these connections go they've
got a tap into a camera for like
literally the meeting of the seven that
is one of those cool things because
starlight doesn't show up to it so it's
it's initially kind of like okay like
starlight misses a meeting of the seven
which as we know is a big no-no right
because like vaud american sits in on
all the meetings and if star light's not
there if aught american is gonna start
asking questions like why is the seven
incomplete what's going on like do they
not have it together is there something
like do we need to consider replacing
them like totally replacing the entire
team with somebody else should we pull
our funding and give it to somebody else
do give it to another group out there or
something like that it looks bad it
looks bad in front of the company it
looks bad in front of the business not
only that Huey has actually been tasked
with tracking down like one of the one
of the superheroes that he basically
killed now for those of you guys who
remember this far back of course this
was Blarney [ __ ] not really this far
back he was like three videos ago two
videos ago or something like that but
this was glory [ __ ] a member of the
teenage kicks who was basically killed
by Huey the idea behind this was that
Blarney [ __ ] was
how resurrected right like he was
literally brought back from the debt the
question is is the brain gonna be the
same is it gonna function in the same
way and what he was picking up from
these various observations after being
cashed by Billy butcher to track down
Blarney [ __ ] and take him out is that no
his brain doesn't really work the same
way right I'm he's just kind of a shell
of his former self you know and it's one
of these things were kind of like okay
like the th kicks are looking for a way
to kind of get rid of him but at the
same time they don't want to put off the
impression like anybody out there they
don't have their house in order right so
like they're trying to find a way to
sort of sway the sweep this under the
rug get rid of it and call him a day
right now from there you pick up with
Huey and Starlin actually having their
drink together and it's kind of a funny
thing because starlights never really
consumed alcohol before and this is kind
of a smart move by Huey right because he
the response of Huey know when she's
like you should come back to my place
the response of Huey is no I don't
really want to and that's a good choice
where that's a good call right never
engage in that kind of activity with
somebody who's intoxicated because who
knows what kind of problems you could
run into but it's a smart move on behalf
of Huey it almost kind of makes him
regretful like man I really wish I'd
gone through with it ultimately he
didn't which again was essentially the
smart move there but if somebody kind of
gives himself a hard time over now one
of the small things did I want to point
out here this is kind of a small thing I
don't want to really delve too hard into
this but there's a moment where Mother's
Milk goes back to his house and looks
for his mom now those are the guys who
know why like don't say anything but
like it's pretty screwed up and like
we'll explain it as we get through this
story but I want you guys to keep that
in the back of your head for a little
while because once we get to that part
you're gonna kind of be like wow that's
kind of that's kind of messed up like
that's that's kind of wild and kind of
screwed up but again there's some great
moments that go on here because
ultimately what you end up having is
kind of like this Park basically where
Huey and starlight meet right I mean the
idea of like them going to a bar was
kinda like okay I mean this is cool
everything but like I feel like the park
is our place right the place where we go
the place where we talk is pretty
romantic and it's actually kind of
intimate here right opening up to each
other in a way that they haven't really
done before now notice they're not
spilling all the secrets about each
other by he's not like hey I work for
this guy Billy butcher and I'm part of a
group called the boys and we're taking
down Supes everywhere we find them he
doesn't really say that to it uh and she
really keeps a lot of those things
secret now she's a little more open than
he has in so far as as she's kinda like
yeah I'm a member of the seven but at
that point it's really public
information and unavoidable right so
she's not really dumping anything that
he couldn't already find out on his own
just by reading like a newspaper or
watching TV when she was officially
inducted onto the team of course her not
spilling the beans about the kind of
thing she did is a way for her to kind
of keep that barrier up and keep herself
emotionally safe so to speak and
sort of intriguing because as a two of
them talk and as the two of them sort of
engaged there's a kind of romance for
him between the two of them while all
that's going on
Blarney [ __ ] basically makes his way
into the apartment of Huey and then Huey
once he arrives back there Velarde [ __ ]
standing there his whole backside
covered with poo basically and things
are kind of popping off quite readily
this is a little bit of a humorous party
here right because when things start
sort of started to get crazy Blarney
[ __ ] can't really talk right I mean he's
just kind of there right he's not really
the way he was before he's just kind of
a nonsensical he's almost kind of
Frankenstein in terms of how he
functions now one of the things he does
were if you if you look at his words and
he kind of sort of makes sense of them
what he wants is his hamster back right
he wants his hamster back he wants it to
return ultimately he starts pissing all
over the place but he wants his hamster
back and ultimately the response of Huey
is no you can't have it because what you
can end up doing it's cram and this
thing of your backside and I rescued him
from that terrible fate a scuffle breaks
out between the two of them and Huey
kills the guy yet again right so this is
one of the things that I want you guys
to notice the nature of the boys if you
look at the progression of Huey it's
very similar to the progression of
Starlite albeit almost kind of opposite
right we're Starlite sort of moving
closer and closer right where she's
getting a hard time by you know from a
train about the fact that like she
missed that the meeting of the seven is
she refers to him is needle and
basically walks off and what kind of
almost kind of takes like a sort of yeah
you know celebrating it when you look at
her experience with with Huey where
she's becoming really a lot more
progressive in terms of like getting out
there and and not really waiting for
marriage and different things like that
when you look at the progression of her
hairdo she's really moving away from
like this ultra conservative Heartland
America girl and like stepping more into
the 21st century when this story takes
place you know when you look at the
character of Huey it's much the same way
Huey was a guy who started out with the
boys and was like yeah I mean I could be
part of this but like don't want to hurt
people like I don't want to do anything
like that you know and the responsibilty
butcher is comes with the territory home
slice so if you want to do it you better
be okay with it
getting into the scenario where he
killed Blarney I've learned he cocked
the first time and then this time
killing him again this really seems to
kind of come to a head with the two
characters when you end up having Huey
travelling out to you essentially the
middle of nowhere right when he when he
approaches Billy butcher he's like hey
man if you had to dispose of a body and
you didn't really want like CSI to find
out that you did it or that you're
involved with it in any form or fashion
or to even be able to identify him how
would you do it and the responsibility
butchers like I put him in an aural
drown the senate on fire that's exactly
what he does right like huey takes the
body he goes out to the middle of
nowhere and throws it inside of an oil
drum and sets it on fire he's met by the
arrival of billy butcher and it's kind
of a cool thing right because what he
has done
here is Huey's gone from a guy who
basically didn't want to have anything
to do with like inflicting harm on other
people because was such a terrible thing
to do really being innocent in a lot of
different ways to becoming a guy who
basically took somebody out even if it
was done unintentionally and then now
intentionally disposing of the body
that's kind of the nature of the beast
is he's progressing in a lot of
different ways and so is starlight the
characters are changing and the
characters are evolving and that's why
stories like this are so cool is because
you watch a person and you see them
progress right it's one of the things
you don't really see in comics all that
often these days even where you see with
new characters but Captain America's
Captain America is Captain America he's
been the same character for like since
he's been exam been in existence since
1941 sure elements of him have changed
but if you go and look at Captain
America in Avengers number four right
when he first showed up again understand
me and Jack Kirby running all the way up
until now he's basically the same
character Batman is basically the same
character Superman basically the same
character they don't change they don't
really a fall they don't become anything
different or anything from what they are
right now that evolution already took
place where that evolution already
happened for the most part and it
happened in an exceedingly short short
amount of time if it even really
happened at all right like how those
characters were were structured in
design when they first popped up is for
the most part how they've always been
but then you follow characters like Huey
who's basically this guy who was thrown
into an impossible situation when his
when his girlfriend or his fiancee was
basically taken out by a superhero who
wanted to get gained some kind of
revenge albeit what he was being asked
to do was pretty extreme all the way up
until now where he's disposing of a body
is pretty intense and that's kind of the
cool thing is that as the story
progresses his character will change
even more his character would will grow
and evolve even more and he'll become
something different than what he is
right now it's a cool change to see you
know it's a it's a it's a cool kind of
evolution form so again the boys is a
pretty strong story and this is one that
I think really stands out the most
because I think what it really does is
it highlights the evolution and the
change of the characters more so than
we've seen at any point up to this
moment so that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explain make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rod 4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
you
[Music]